(audience cheering)
- So, why did you call your album,
it's Versions of Me, right?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] So it's all these
different versions of you.
Why did you,
- [Anitta] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love this.
- [Anitta] So, this album cover, each one,
the one in the center is me right now.
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm.
- [Anitta] Or maybe not, I'm
joking, it's me right now.
- (laughing)
- And then, going to the others,
just one me, one intervention,
one plastic surgery before.
So, before-
- Oh, it's because of that.
It's because of plastic surgery.
That's what you mean by the versions.
- In the picture, yes, but I actually have
different like, char, like my
personality's kind of crazy.
I wake up one day,
- [Kelly] Me too,
I'm like how many people are in here?
- [Anitta] Exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Anitta] That's when my friends, they,
whenever I wake up they wait 15 minutes
to see who is in charge.
- [Kelly] Who are you?
- And they're like, oh, let's
see who is commanding today.
And they've been like, okay,
today is the cute one, let's go.
- [Kelly] (laughing)
- And they like, I just have
so many people inside here.
I can't be like-
- I like to call that artistic.
- Yeah, right??
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Right here, I was like
waiting here for the COVID test,
like 20 minutes in a car,
I was just like, listening
to classic music and reading a book.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my manager was
like, what's happening?
- You're like, I'm chill.
- And then I just come back
and start talking about
- Yeah.
- the crazy night I had last time.
But, the cover, the album cover is just me
before each plastic surgery I've done,
And I've done a bunch.
- I love the you're so honest about it.
Not everybody's honest about that.
That's awesome.
- 'Cause I couldn't, I, I am so bad lying.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh, me too.
- I'm terrible
- I get stressed,
- at it.
- I sweat.
- I'm a terrible liar.
- Even if it's like
a half truth, yeah.
- So I used to work in a
store before everything.
And my first job was in a store like,
and I was so bad at it 'cause
people were wearing things
and I couldn't tell
they were looking good.
So, but I needed for them to buy it.
- Yeah. But then you're,
like that's not for you.
- I was like, nah.
- [Kelly] (laughing)
And then I just used to say,
this old lady came this day,
and she wanted to buy
pants, like jeans for his,
for her grandson.
And it was like $75.
There was another that were like, $40,
but the same, kind of the same thing.
- Yeah.
- So I said, I, I felt
like poor the lady she's,
and I said, no, lady, come here,
there is one that is cheaper.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's the same thing.
- You're like the worst
salesman you don't upsell.
(audience laughing)
- And the manager came to me and said,
you get percentage, are you dumb?
And I said, she was just so cute!
I couldn't make her spend 75
if she could spend just 40.
- [Kelly] That's nice, that's kind.
- But, then you don't
- He's the jerk.
- make money!
- I know, I'm not good
at upselling either.
I'm like you can have it or
not or, I'm fine with either.
- [Anitta] I was very bad.